dans une interview accordée à combiner
il ya jean pierre foucault qui a balayé
d'un revers de la main toutes les
critiques sur un concours miss france
c'est vrai qu'on a entendu plein de
choses sur miss france
et voilà jean pierre foucault il a tout
dit l'été sans langue de bois
beauchamp pierre que j'embrasse et bien
sûr on regardera les miss que si c'est
jean pierre foucault ou encore la
présentation cette année un voile
incarne bella craindrait il n'y a rien à
craindre ce que c'est le meilleur mais
je dois bien car on va pas voir non pas
voir une mauvaise idée
tf1 parce qu'en ce moment je vois que
toulouse chamboule-tout away non là
j'espère voilà c'est parti regarder un
concours mais sexy s'est présentée par
un vieux monsieur zahoui est mais ils
ont raison tous ces gens là sauf que
c'est l'émission de divertissement qui
fait le plus grand nombre de
téléspectateurs chaque année sauf que il
ya des milliers de jeunes filles qui
sont princesse déjà chez elle qui rêve
de devenir reine
sauf que la miss france qui étaient dus
chaque fois bien sa vie est transformée
c'est un ascenseur social extraordinaire
et sauf que si ça vous plaît pas vous
regardez pas raison d'efforts son
émission c'est une émission qui qui qui
qui qui lui colle à la peau et avec qui
il a fait les beaux jours de cette
émission il la défend à chaque fois et
voilà il défend aussi à travers la
défense de l'émission c'est la défense
des jeunes filles parce qu'à beaucoup de
condescendance en disant c'est un marché
au bétail sont des filles comme ça
ben non quand vous dites ça sous couvert
de défendre les femmes en fait vous avez
lycée les femmes et vous dit qu'elles
sont incapables de décider de leur
destin
elles ont envie de le faire elle va très
bien voyez moi moi je bravo jean pierre
c'est un excellent animateur d'abord il
a un charisme fou il est sympathique
comme tout aimé moi j'aurais michel
drucker avec de rigueur michel drucker
et puis après que tu as bien sûr y'a pas
de tête de personne personne personne
personne et là dans la fois on me disait
ce qui est d un garçon vraiment que tu
aime beaucoup à mon métier c'est vrai
qu'il était tout de suite j'ai déjà
perdu la bou c'est un amour de mecs
c'est vrai que j'avais raison
un duo incroyable sectionnelles gens
pillaient gentil bien et je vais vous
dire moi si j'avais été rtl et là je le
dis un régis ravanas voilà mon ami un le
président d'air telle est la meilleure
chose ils auraient dû rappeler jean
pierre foucault pour rappeler stéphane
bern c'est jean-pierre qu'ils aient les
meilleures audiences sur intel
il aurait fait un coup exceptionnel
après jean pierre g
s'il a envie de travailler tous les
jours faire de la radio tout ça
maintenant je pense qu'il est tellement
haut que ça doit peut-être un peu embêté
mais ici il avait eu vraiment essayé de
le convaincre
ça aurait été énorme jean pierre
foucault dans un jeu sur un t elle là je
peux vous dire ça aurait fait moi je
vous le dis + 30 % d'audience greer est
je le signe tout de suite voilà ici et
voilà raconte et si un jour jean michel
mr rachète rtl eh ben on fera notre
grille nous ment voilà c'est la seule
émission avec le tonneau france qui
réunit un peu toute la france et ses
régions ses terres à chacun vote a pour
sa région d'origine et cetera comme sur
le fond son visite un peu crade
hélicoptère extra c'est des émissions
pour faire un grand paris xi